when most people buy a house they need
to borrow money for some part of the
purchase price of the house so let's say
that we have a house right over here and
the purchase price is two hundred two
hundred thousand dollars and I want to
buy this house and I've saved up forty
thousand dollars I have saved up forty
thousand dollars so this is my savings
and so I will use this as a down payment
but I still need to borrow the rest of
the money in order to get to two hundred
thousand dollars so I'm going to have to
get I am going to have to get the
balance the hundred and sixty thousand
dollars as as a loan as a loan and the
type of loan that people get or that
they usually get to buy a house is
called a mortgage mortgage and a
mortgage is really just a loan where if
you don't pay the loan off the person
that you borrowed the money from gets
the house so another way to think about
it is it's a loan that is secured by the
house until you pay off the loan when
you pay off the loan it is your house to
keep it at any point if you don't pay it
the bank can come and take the house and
that is called a foreclosure now what I
want to focus on in this video is the
types of mortgage loans you will
typically see and give you at least the
beginning of an understanding of how to
understand what these different types of
loans mean so in all of these scenarios
let's just assume that I'm in the market
to borrow one hundred sixty thousand
dollars for this house I'm about to buy
so if you look at any financial website
or any of the major even search web
portals they'll give you quotes for
mortgage rates and you'll see something
like this I made these numbers really
simple normally you'll have some
decimals here 5.25% 4.18 percent i mean
these numbers a little bit simpler just
just to make them simpler so these are
the typical types of mortgages you will
see but if you contact a mortgage broker
they'll have many many more types more
exotic types but these are the most
common this is what we'll cover in this
video and hopefully they'll give you a
sense of what the other types of
mortgage is like a 30-year fixed
mortgage means that your payment and
your interest rate are fake
just over 30 years and over the course
of those 30 years you will pay off your
loan so in this situation so let me so
this is a 30 we write it over here
so let's think about a 30 year fixed 30
year fixed mortgage what will happen is
you will have a fixed pit you will have
a fixed mortgage payment every month so
and I'll draw a little bar graph to show
the size of your payment you'll see why
I'm doing that in a second so let me
just draw a little bit of a graph here
so each of these blocks represent your
monthly payment for that month and I'm
just going to make up the number let's
say it is $2,000 I actually haven't
figured out the math of what is the
exact payment for a 30-year fixed with
the 5% interest rate for $160,000 but
let's just say for the sake of
simplicity let's say it's $2,000 a month
so this height right over here let me
make it make it like this so this is
$2,000 a month $2,000 this is month 1
then you will pay $2,000 in month 2 so
on and so forth all the way if you have
30 years times 12 months you're going to
get all the way to month 360 and you're
going to and that is going to be your
last payment month 360 is the last
payment in year 30 and you would have
paid off your loan the interesting thing
here is in the first month since you've
borrowed so much from the bank you've
borrowed $160,000 the interest that you
have to pay on it is going to be pretty
large so most of the initial payments
are going to be interest so I'm going to
do the interest in this magenta color so
in that first payment
that's not magenta this is magenta in
that first payment it's going to be
mostly interest and you're going to pay
a little bit off of the actual loan so
that right there is your principal
payment so let's say after that first
month the principal part of that $2,000
is and I'm just making up numbers for
the sake of simplicity let's say that
that is $200 and the interest portion
the interest portion is $1,800 I'm not
actually working it through with these
assumptions you don't even have to
assume that it's $160,000 loan but the
general idea here is
after this first month you would have
paid $200 off of your loan so if it was
$160,000 loan after that first month you
don't owe $160,000 - 2000 because 1800
of that was interest you now owe
$160,000 - $200 so you now one hundred
and fifty nine thousand one hundred
fifty nine thousand eight hundred
dollars and so in the next period your
interest is going to be a little bit
lower it's going to be just a little bit
lower and your principal since you're
staying the same fixed payment of two
thousand dollars every month it's going
to be a little bit higher maybe it's
going to be in the next month something
slightly higher I don't know two hundred
and two dollars and you keep going like
that and the math works out they figure
out the payment so that by that last
payment by that last payment you're
paying very little interest you're
paying very little interest and most of
that last payment is principal it's
actually being used for the loan and
then after that last payment the loan is
paid off and this will happen over
thirty years this is a 30-year term a
15-year fixed is the same exact idea
except instead of going from instead of
this being instead of it taking 30 years
to pay off the loan you're going to do
it after over 15 years so instead of it
being 360 months in the 15-year case it
is going to be it is going to be 180
months and because of that your payment
for the same loan amount is going to be
higher every month because you're paying
it off quicker you're paying it off in
fewer months instead of $2,000 a month
maybe it is something like 2,800 2,800
dollars a month for the 15-year case
you're paying it off quicker the 5/1 arm
case and you'll see and there are many
types of arms and I'm explained to you
in a second one an arm is but the five
one is the most typical and I'll explain
what that means a second arm means arm
means adjustable rate mortgage
adjustable adjustable rate mortgage and
as you see in in these situations we had
the word fixed and
they're they're called fixed because the
interest rate was fixed whatever your
whatever your remaining loan balance was
you paid the same fixed amount of
interest out for the next period so for
this 30-year fixed we are being quoted a
5% fixed rate over the next 30 years
will not change for the 15 year we're
quoted a 4% fixed rate for the arm the
rate can change when someone tells you
about a 5-1 arm they're actually talking
about something called a hybrid arm but
the general idea behind an adjustable
rate mortgage is the amount of interest
you pay on your remaining balance will
change and will change according to some
index the most typical types of
adjustable rate mortgages are things
like this hybrid arm so this is a hybrid
and a hybrid it's viewed as a mixture of
two things or a combination of two
things and what a hybrid adjustable rate
mortgage is is it has a fixed rate for
some period of time in this case it's a
fixed rate for it is a fixed rate for
five years and then the interest rate
can change once a year after that or
every one years after that and that's
what this right over here is telling you
so the in case of in the case of an
adjustable rate mortgage your payment
might look something like this
and I'll just make up numbers for
simplicity just to give you the flavor
what it might look like so months in the
case of a 5-1 your first five years are
fixed so your first five years so a
month one it's going to look like that
month two is going to look like that you
go all the way to month sixty which is
the last month in the five years and
it's going to look like that so that's
one that's month - that is month 60 this
is the course of five years this is over
the course of five years and over the
course of five years its to sit the the
idea is fairly similar you're going to
pay some part of this is going to be
some part of this is going to be
interest and the remainder is going to
actually be used to pay down the loan
and each month you're going to pay down
a little bit more of the loan and you're
going to have to pay a little less than
interest when we get a little bit bigger
and you're gonna have to pay a little
bit less at interest and you're gonna
have to pay a little bit less than
interest because you've you have
less remaining on your loan and by month
but by by year five or month sixty you
still haven't paid your loan off so
maybe the interest is right over here
maybe the interest is right over there
it actually it'll probably be higher
than that I don't want to be too exact
but maybe your interest is going to be
right over here and then and then this
is what you're paying down from the loan
for it a hybrid adjustable rate mortgage
after that five year period the bank can
now change the interest rate and the
interest rate is going to be dependent
on some kind of underlying thing that
everyone is paying attention to and so
if that underlying thing increases in
interest so in this five in this five
one arm it starts off at a three percent
interest if because of this thing that
we're paying attention to and I'll talk
more about that in a second interest
rates all of a sudden go up then let's
say they go up a lot then all of a
sudden your payment could increase your
payment could increase because the
general idea behind a 5/1 arm is that
you are still going to pay it off in 30
years so they typically I should say
have a 30-year term so if you just stick
with this loan you never try to borrow
other money to replace this loan which
is called a refinance if you just stick
with this loan it will take you 30 years
to pay it off but after the first five
years the amount of interest you pay
might actually change and so your
payment might actually change so if the
interest rate goes up if the interest
rate goes up all of a sudden you might
have to pay a lot more interest all of a
sudden in month sixty one or in year six
in year six in year six let me do that
in I can do that that part of that same
blue color and that for year six since
this is a 5-1 arm they can't change the
interest rate again until year seven so
you'll pay this constant amount until
year seven and then they can change the
rate again and there usually are some
caps on how much they can change the
rate each year or how much they can
change the rate in total but it is a
little bit riskier because you really
don't know what your payment might be in
year six or your seven especially if
interest rates go up a lot now you might
be asking what
Germans what that new interest rate is
in after the five years and they usually
pick some type of index the most typical
are is especially the United States
Treasury securities so they look at the
10-year Treasury interest rate that the
essentially the government has to pay
when it borrows money and they'll
usually take some premium over this so
if the one year or is the ten-year
Treasuries at 2% the bank might put in
your in your loan documents that after
the initial five year fixed period you
will pay a ten-year Treasury rate plus
maybe you'll pay that plus one percent
so you start off paying the three
percent that's fixed even if the
Treasury does all sorts of crazy things
even if it goes up to five percent
you're just going to keep paying the
three percent for the first five years
but then in that sixth year let's say
that let me write it right over here
let's say that in year six the Treasury
the Treasury security rate now has
bumped up to four percent then by
contract by what's in your loan document
you're going to have to pay that plus
one percent so now your mortgage is
going to reset to have a five percent
rate have a higher rate you might get
lucky though maybe you're maybe the
Treasury rate goes down maybe it goes to
one percent and then your mortgage rate
would actually be one percent plus one
percent so it could actually go down to
two percent but the general idea is is
that that's a little riskier because you
really don't know how predictable that
payment is going to be and if you look
at most you know most times if you look
at quoted interest rates you'll see that
the 30-year fixed rate is higher than
the 15-year fixed rate which is higher
than the adjustable rate and that's
because the bank there's a couple of
different forms of risk but the bank is
taking the least amount of risk on the
adjustable rate mortgage and taking the
most risks on the 30-year fixed and the
biggest risk here there's the risk that
you don't pay it off but that's why they
like to see a down payment because they
can get the house back and hopefully the
house doesn't devalue by more than your
down payment but even more than that
there's an interest rate risk because
what happens if the bank lends you money
lends you a big chunk of money at 5% and
that interest rates go up to 6% 7% what
if they go up to 10% what
the bank's borrowing cost the amount of
money the bank has to pay people to
borrow money goes up to ten percent then
I'll be taking a loss on your loan so
they and they're fixing it for so long
that's why they want to make up for some
of that risk by charging you higher
interest a 15-year loan a little bit
less risk so they'll have a little bit
lower interest a 5/1 arm even lower risk
they're only fixed for five years and
then after that they can float this will
float with the prevailing interest rate
on an annual basis so hopefully that
gives you a little bit of a primer of
mortgage interest rates but I want to I
want to really you know make sure that
you don't view just this video is that
all you need to take out a loan it's
super important to read the fine details
on on what's happening with that loan
especially if you're buying something
more if you're taking out a more exotic
loan like an adjustable rate mortgage or
an interest-only loan or an option an
option arm or anything of those more
exotic things